y situaciones que pueden encontrarnos y
sorprendernos en cualquier momento
podemos estar en el banco en la parada
de colectivo trabajando o estudiando
pero podemos prepararnos para responder
a este tipo de situaciones que no
sabemos qué es lo que nos va a suceder
ni cuándo
les voy a contar algo que me sucedió
hace un tiempo estábamos acá en munro
jugando al pádel con amigos y resulta
que viene la encargada del lugar a
pedirnos ayuda desesperada alguien en
otra cancha se había caído al piso no
sabían el motivo no sabían por qué
y nadie sabía qué hacer
casualmente un amigo y yo que ya éramos
bomberos en esa época
fuimos y pudimos asistirlo
no siempre hay gente que pueda responder
a este tipo de situaciones
por eso es importante que ahora no le
voy a mostrar les voy a explicar les voy
a enseñar de qué manera pueden llegar a
reaccionar y actuar en caso de que algo
por el estilo les suceda
vamos a aprender a hacer rcp solo con
manos
rcp quiere decir reanimación
cardiopulmonar y lo vamos a hacer solo
con las manos
vamos a suponer que estamos acá en el
centro universitario y de pronto alguien
con quien estamos gracias al este
alguien con quien estamos charlando se
cae al piso sin motivo aparente estaba
en un perfecto estado de salud y de
pronto se cayó entonces yo me voy a
acercar al lado de él voy a arrodillarme
y le voy a hablar al oído me escuchas me
escuchas qué pasa algo le voy a hablar a
los dos oídos porque puede ser
hipoacúsico o puede ser sordo
si no responde a este tipo de
de estímulo lo que voy a hacer es
realizar un estímulo doloroso con los
pulgares le voy a hacer un estímulo
doloroso acá hay un huequito a la altura
de la clavícula donde lo voy a apretar
fuerte yo quiero que esta persona
reaccione se mueva hago una mueca o algo
si tampoco esto con este estímulo
tampoco lo hace voy a entender que esta
persona está inconsciente y que no
respira entonces voy a empezar con
maniobras de reanimación voy a colocar
mis manos en el centro del pecho
voy a sacar la ropa voy a entrelazar mis
manos y voy a colocar mis manos en el
centro del pecho y voy a comenzar a
comprimir
voy a pedirle a alguien le voy a decir
vos la chica del pañuelo negro anda
llama al 107 y decirle que tengo una
persona que está inconsciente que no
respira y que estamos empezando a
reanimación esto nos da margen para el
error van a venir rápido si no se van a
confundir con otros síntomas y después
de esto venid y decime qué es lo que te
dijeron yo tengo que asegurarme que el
servicio de emergencia está viniendo por
otra parte voy a averiguar si en el
lugar donde estamos
hay un desfibrilador un dea defibrilador
externo automático ak el centro
universitario hay uno así que voy a
pedir que me lo alcancen
y sin dejar de comprimir vamos a
aprenderlo y vamos a realizar
todo lo que el desfibrilador nos diga
[Música]
el paciente
despegue los electrodos blancos de la
caja gris de plástico
fije los electrodos a la piel desnuda
exactamente como se muestra en la
ilustración
retire la ropa que cubre el pecho del
paciente
manténgase alejado del paciente
analizando el ritmo cardíaco
manténgase alejado del paciente descarga
aconsejable manténgase alejado del
paciente pulse ahora el botón naranja
parpadeante descarga aplicada verifique
si se ha llamado al servicio médico de
urgencias puede tocar al paciente inicie
resucitación cardiopulmonar muy bien
gracias al este
a plató las letras animales
esto que acabamos de hacer lo hicimos de
esta manera porque éramos dos operadores
que quien significa esto que se hubiera
estado yo solo con la víctima lo que
tengo que hacer es antes de empezar a
comprimir ir a buscar el desfibrilador
si sé que hay traerlo colocarlo y recién
después empezar a comprimir una vez que
yo empiezo a hacer compresiones en el
pecho no voy a parar
hasta cuando no voy a parar hasta que la
persona reaccione
hasta que llegue el servicio de
emergencia y me diga quédate tranquilo
que yo me hago cargo o hasta que el
lugar se vuelva inseguro
ahora cuando la persona reaccione
estamos en el centro universitario no me
va a decir gracias la verdad menos mal
que te animaste ahora porque tengo que
entrar a la clase de química
tampoco me va a preguntar si que le pasó
y le voy a decir nada quedate tranquilo
estuviste muerto un ratito pero vas a
llegar temprano si entonces lo que
tenemos que hacer saber que el
desfibrilador lo puede utilizar
cualquiera cualquier persona puede
utilizar un dea solo que hay que
escuchar las indicaciones que el
desfibrilador nos va a ir diciendo
en argentina casi 40 mil personas por
año padecen de muerte súbita son casi
110 por día
y de la gente que se junta alrededor
cuando se cae una persona al piso sólo 1
de cada 80 personas sabe responder a
estas situaciones y sabe hacer el reset
por eso es importante multiplicar estas
técnicas
la palabra cardíaca
es se produce de forma inesperada y
repentina entonces lo que nosotros
tenemos que hacer es rápidamente empezar
a comprimir en el pecho porque nosotros
tenemos que comprimir a la altura de las
tetillas en el esternón en el hueso que
tenemos acá delante y tendrían que ser
las compresiones rápidas 100 a 120
compresiones por minuto y profundas
entre 5 y 6 centímetros cuando la parada
cada día se produce esto se produce por
una fibrilación del corazón o por
cualquier otra rítmica cardíaca
cuando esto sucede el corazón deja de
latir como late normalmente tomando
sangre y expulsando la para llevar
oxígeno a todo el cuerpo y se empieza a
mover erráticamente lo que hace el
desfibrilador es justamente detectar
esos movimientos erráticos pararlo y
reiniciar los resetear lo como si fuera
el botón de la computadora cuando se
cuelga la máquina recién estábamos
hablando de tecnología se colgó la
máquina apretamos el botón de reinicio
todo vuelve al principio y podemos
volver a trabajar normalmente
cualquier persona como dije antes puede
utilizar un desfibrilador
entonces lo que tenemos que hacer y
saber sobre todo como dije antes al no
haber este movimiento de sangre ya que
el corazón no está latiendo con las
compresiones nosotros vamos a reemplazar
esos movimientos vamos a complementar
los movimientos que el corazón no está
haciendo
la sangre y transforma oxígeno
a todo el cuerpo pero el cuerpo no
utiliza el 100% del oxígeno que hay en
sangre entonces nosotros al hacer este
movimiento vamos a estar haciendo que el
oxígeno que hay todavía en la sangre
llegue al cerebro
entonces lo que hay que
la utilización del del dea y el fsp
rápidamente lo que al utilizarlo rápido
lo que nos va a dar es mayor
probabilidad de sobrevida en las
personas cada minuto que pasa sin
hacerle nada a una persona que está en
esta situación es un 10% menos de
probabilidades de sobrevida por eso es
que rápidamente tenemos que empezar con
esto quiere decir que si en cinco
minutos nosotros no le realizan ninguna
ninguna maniobra a esta persona estuvo
casi cinco minutos sin oxígeno en el
cerebro entonces puede reaccionar tal
vez sí pero puede ser que lo haga y que
quede con alguna secuela
entonces
lo que tenemos que poner en práctica a
nosotros es la cadena de supervivencia
la cadena de supervivencia consta de
cinco eslabones el primero es llamar
rápidamente al servicio de emergencia el
segundo es comprimir rápido y fuerte a
la altura del pecho como dije antes
entre las tetillas la tercera es el uso
de un desfibrilador
la cuarta y la quinta que están de otro
color son las que
nosotros no vamos a poder realizar
siguen las dos las tres primeras la
llamada las compresiones y la
utilización de un desfibrilador si es
que lo hay hay algo que hay que saber
que el desfibrilador por sí solo no
sirve no es que yo vengo traigo pongo el
desfibrilador y edificadora hace todo el
desfibrilador es un excelente
complemento para hacer maniobras de
reanimación entonces sólo no lo puedo
utilizar pero si si yo se puede hacer
maniobras de reanimación sin tener un
desfibrilador
entonces hay distintas formas en que
nosotros podemos
guiarnos para llegar a esa cantidad de
compresiones en 100 a 120 por minuto
por ejemplo guiándonos con canciones con
música
yo lo que le voy a pagar a preguntar a
proponer digo perdón es decirles que yo
les voy a explicar cómo se hace esto que
no se basan solo con la teoría entonces
yo les voy a pedir que se paren por
favor
todo
lo que vamos a hacer ahora es lo
siguiente yo les voy a mostrar como son
como nos tenemos que poner para realizar
estas maniobras
además también despejamos un poco la
modorra así estamos medio
vamos a estirar los brazos hacia
adelante
a esta vamos a entrelazar los dedos con
la mano que ustedes le quede más cómoda
bajo la que quieran
y vamos a realizar un leve movimiento
hacia adelante todo el cuerpo no solo
los brazos y de la cintura sale el
movimiento perfecto muy bien pero como
les dije antes para poder seguir el
ritmo y no perdernos en la cantidad de
compresiones que tenemos que hacer en
esto de 100 a 120 por minuto lo que
vamos a hacer es guiarnos con música hay
muchos temas que siguiendo esto que es
el ritmo de la canción con los beats por
minuto que tiene cada tema nosotros
podemos llegar
a las 100 ó 120 compresiones por minuto
hay que tener en cuenta de no cantar la
canción en voz alta no va a quedar muy
bien en esta situación pero si
mentalmente entonces les voy a pedir
otra cosita más que es ir en 180 grados
mirando hacia la pared del fondo
levanten el asiento
y vamos a usar el borde del asiento como
si fuera el pecho de la víctima
sí
estamos
vamos todos
cuando yo cuente 3 vamos a apoyar la
mano como aprendimos recién entrelazadas
en el borde muy bien y vamos a empezar a
comprimir
a la una a las dos y a las tres
[Música]
la alegría magdalena
después de los muy bien
muy bien
felicitaciones y acaso veía bien todos a
la par vieron que se puede llevar el
ritmo y si uno se acuerda de esas
canciones cualquiera hay otras más que
también pueden ayudarnos la marcha de
san lorenzo back in black day 6 y todo
depende del gusto musical de cada uno
yo simplemente quería decirle después de
estas indicaciones cortitas esto es algo
muy importante que todo el mundo lo sepa
siempre nosotros con los chicos de
defensa siempre decimos
nosotros enseñamos esto por egoísmo
porque yo quiero que al lado mío haya
alguien que me pueda ayudar a mí si a mí
me pasa algo porque cualquiera de
nosotros que está al lado de cualquiera
podría ayudarlo
desde que trabajo en la dirección
general de defensa civil ya llevamos
capacitados casi a más de seis mil
personas en esta técnica
hoy cuando ustedes entraron por esa
puerta quizás no sabían que iban a ver
esto no sabía que iban a ser menos
comprensión de acciones de decisión
pero yo sinceramente me voy feliz de
haber podido
y haber hecho esta charla y me voy feliz
porque entrarán como dije antes sin
saber qué era lo que venían a ver y
ahora se van a ir como 100 nuevos
reanimadores todos vamos a poder ayudar
de ahora en más y que el ritmo no pare
gracias
[Música]